Howard Weiss, a mathematics professor at Georgia Tech has teamed up with Vicki
Hertzberg from Emory School of Nursing.
They are the principal investigators in
A newly released study on how certain
respiratory illnesses might spread during air travel."
Herzberg: "So we were curious as
to how much movement had to do with
transmission of disease in the airplane."
Weiss. "This is a project to quantify the
transmission of large droplet-mediated
respiratory infectious diseases in an
airplane cabin during flight." The study,
published in Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences, tracked passenger
movement during 10 cross-country flights
and then created thousands of simulated
flight models based on that data.
Weiss: "And then we leveraged that to be able to create thousands and thousands of different flights
where on each flight, each simulated flight, each passenger has the movement
of some passenger who is seated in that seat on one of the ten flights."
Their findings suggest that germs probably don't spread any faster aboard airplanes
than they do in other common settings.
Their chief finding:
Herzberg: "If somebody is seated either one row ahead or one row behind or two seats lateral to
an Infectious passenger, then they
are the most likely to become infected."
Weiss: "If you're seated further than a few feet from an infected passenger and you
practice good hand hygiene, you're very
unlikely to become infected."
They also sampled the cabin air during these flights.
Herzeberg: "Boeing refreshes its air,  I'm told, much more frequently than your average office building.
On all these surfaces and and in all the air samples, we submitted them for testing with a panel of
18 common respiratory viruses that might be transmitted and all of those samples were negative.
The study focused only on these common
respiratory viruses and how they might
spread in a passenger airliner.
It did not look at other places in which passengers might get infected, like in
the airport gate house area before
boarding or standing in a line at a
hotel registration desk or riding in a
crowded subway car.
It also did not measure the many other ways travelers might get sick during travel, such as
picking up germs from surfaces that a sick passenger has touched.
Weiss: "I could also be infected and cough in my hand, and then go to the lavatory a touch a knob, and
then you go to the lavatory, touch the
same knob and then you wipe your eye or your nose."
But frequent hand-washing or using a hand sanitizer during travel can go a long way
to keep you from getting sick.
Herzberg: "The findings from this study haven't stopped me from flying."